we will not accept North Korea as a  nuclear state  north Korea has helped release all clear  provocation we're sneaking around right  on the edge of international waters the  engine killer who ordered me to give the  Americans everything they need you will  see the pilot right now this stuff is  the best shot we've got a completing our  mission we are now in control understand  start to gear down with this is your big  secret ironic since we support it it  will come back eighty one please respond  eighty one do you read me  we're upside down your passion  we're at the bottom of the ocean  if you do this we're daddy  we're all dead there's a reason that  we're in this mess now this is worth  dying for  you